Sam Beekman freed has officially been
arrested in the Bahamas and is now
waiting to be extradited to the US the
southern district of New York shared a
sealed indictment with the government of
the Bahamas the night before SPF was
supposed to testify before Congress that
secret indictment got unsealed the very
next morning charging same with eight
criminal counts including conspiracy to
defraud the United States wire fraud
Securities fraud and money laundering
that is not very shocking what is
shocking is that Sam didn't flee while
he could instead he chose to stay in the
Bahamas even though the Bahamas has an
extradition treaty with the U.S it's
probably because he thought he didn't do
anything legally wrong in the U.S which
if you watched our video on this you
know that's probably true link below but
the problem is in the US it doesn't
matter if he actually committed a crime
or not no if the public hates you enough
prosecutors will eventually find a way
to take you down which is why